SMOKE.
IT
WITH US FOR A WHILE.
ANDERSON?
MARQUEHANK YOU.
>>> INLORIDA, TAKEISST A BOOGNI0
BOOKS TOGIN OUR BOOK.
S RE
AFTER
HIE " TH HE POEM SHADRATION HER
AT THEOOL LIEN AVA
STUDENTS UIL
COMPLAINT.
T T W, TH
NOW THE DIST SAYS ONLY STUDENTS.
EW OF TOOK ISSUEITH.
E'VEE BELL
BEAST.
AND NOTIONS OF TALWAYSEA
JUST IS ISN'T ALWAY
JUSTICE.
AND YET THE DAWN IRE, WEIT, SOM
THATSIMPLY
>> ANDMAA GORMAN JOINS US
DO THAT INAUGURAL POEM AGAIN. L.
GHAIT
CIUMS. YNITIAL
UNOK WAS RESTRICTED BY
HAD NO ERE I THINK MY FIRS WL E
INAUGUAND COOF ERAT FROM AHELFT.
ANHE FLISIDE
THIS ANGUISH PAIN  OF THE
W
LE TE EMLV IN THMOMENTDEMOCRATI.
TO HRESENTATION ROM YOUNPE
STT
>> YOU KNOW, TS OBVIOUSLY IN PL
COUNTRY.
D ARENTS HAVE
NOT READ ANY OF
THEYFTA LIST OOKGANIZATION,
CORGANIZATION, THAT
REMOVED.
D THAT IN AND SHOW
UP AHOOL BOARDAND THE BOOKS AREE
I THINK YOU GBSOLUTELY TO
OIS WHICH IS
THAT.AKES IS ONE PERS TEN ISN'T'
NEED TO READ THAT WORKINT.D AT
PQUAW WITAT
THATM CAN EVENE FILLED OUT
ACLYAN TECOME BEIN F
COMMUNITY, THALIAN WHAT WE'RE WI
LOOPHOLE IN THEEDUCATIONAL SYSS
E A SMALL
SELECT GROF O
>> GET YOUR BOOK, YOU'TO GO HE
Y BOOK THAT'BEEN BD OTHEOKS THA
THAT SAME SCHOOL DUEAT
PLOF WHATSIS, , HESCHOOL.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE TOP IN
THROUOU SAID,F CHW NEED JUMER
MEDIA SPECIALISTS, PROVING
REBOOK, THOSE TYS E GOINY PEDED
FREEGIG
EXF O PULLA BOOKF EXPERIENCE ITD
ABOUT THE ROLE OF TAD AT PEACE
GOING IKK THATY
.K THE ISSUE
ONE PERSON'S DISLIKE FORLYHING
D TERSO CESS FORR PEOPLE WHO
STILL WANT THAORN.>> THERE HAV
QUESON
E MOTIVATION ND THE NUMBEDOINTHS
TA ORTI
GROUP OFEO LEADER OF
GROUP FR
AND ST WANT TO PLAF AT SHE HAD
>> W DIRECTING THAT?
>>ERS UNIONS AND OUR T AND A LO
TE UNIS ARE ALSO HEAVILY BACKINM
AT PUTTING INT.
>> WHY WOULD THEY WANT MORE KIDS
>> BECAUSE I DOW
FAMILY UNIT,AT
VALUES.
IT BREAKS DOWN A LOT OF THGS THI
IT CHANGES THE WAY PND
POLITICS. WHICH IS SORT OF
FASCINATING UNPE  AT TH FOR THI
MA
CONSPIRACY BY TEACHER UNIONS ANA
FAMILYDOES THAT MAKE A TO YOU?
ILU MAKES TO
I BASW YEARS.R EXAMPLE, OE OK
FROM JUST 11 BBANNING TIVE OF T
WHBELIE
INDOCTRINATION OS OFF SEXUALITY.
CHILDREN ANDE ISSUES IA SATHEY'I
THE LOVE ONIRE'RE ALSO PARTNERI
PAN-AMERICELHERS.
HOW PE
ELY.
SOIFANT TO LEARN MORABOUT BOOK
REMO ALSO HOW N
HAVE YOUR VOICHEAR